the amount of people that start reading
something that they heard their friend
talk about and just decide oh this is
stupid they're either giving up on
curiosity or conviction curiosity and
conviction are important because if you
don't have the conviction that there's
something Brewing or your Spidey senses
are talking to you or you're on to
something you're going to give up I
don't think I realized prior to writing
this book how big of a deal curiosity is
in My Success curiosity is what gets me
down these paths humility is often one
of the reasons it sticks I don't value
my time the way that people with far
less valuable time value theirs